that all deserve equal justice under the
law
from the privileged to the impoverished
in an imperfect world
the judge considered so many hurdles
so the judge conquered so many hurdles
and today stands as one of the most
experienced individuals ever nominated
to the supreme court
for this reason the judges also be loved
by individuals and organizations across
the political spectrum
i went through her record carefully and
never did i find one instance of a peer
or colleague or associate say one
negative word about her it was
incredible when we go through these
records you often find someone here and
there who will bad-mouth the individual
who knew them not with just judge
jackson
unless we forget the judge is popular in
the minds of the american people
a gallup poll released after her hearing
showed nearly 60 percent of the public
supports our confirmation
10 points above the historical norm
and there is no question here the
country by and large wants the senate to
confirm judge jackson
police chiefs want to confirm judge
jackson
conservative and moderate and liberal
judges all want us to confirm judge
jackson
and i thank my colleagues in this
chamber who worked in good faith
to make sure the senate can finish its
work today
finally as i've said many times
the judge belongs
on the supreme court
by that i mean something very specific
in our nation's history 115 individuals
have been confirmed by this body to
serve on the supreme court of the united
states
of those 108
have been white men
only four
have been women
only two
have been african-american
but katanji brown-jackson will be the
first
african-american woman ever
to hold the title of justice
think about the impact
that will have on our democracy
untold millions of kids will open
textbooks and see pictures of just
justice jackson among the highest ranks
of our public figures how many millions
of kids in generations passed
could have benefited from such a role
model
how many would-be justices lawyers
doctors generals business people
have been lost to history
precisely because their history books
had few if any role models that they
could relate to
we certainly have a long way to go on
the road to true justice
but by confirming judge jackson today
we are taking a bold step forward
towards reaching the full realization of
our country's promise
we will make it far more likely that
girls across america will feel precisely
what judge jackson felt herself when she
was a kid
nobody can stop me i can do this too
i am brilliant to i belong to
for all these reasons increasing the
diversity of the court
has been of one my one of my highest
priorities and one of the highest
priorities of our senate democratic
majority of whom i am so proud
justice jackson is the most important
example but we've been working on this
for over a year
of the 58 senate confirmed federal
judges since we took the majority three
quarters have been women two-thirds have
been people of color
and it's not just racial or and gender
diversity that matters we have strived
to lift up judges that bring diversity
through their experience
more public defenders in our courts more
civil rights lawyers more election
lawyers
when americans of all walks of life come
before the court
they should have confidence that those
who don the robes have the ability to
walk in their own shoes
to see and understand their side of the
story
and then apply the law properly
according to the facts
one judge at a time one judge at a time
this majority is expanding the
possibility of who merits consideration
to the bench
and i would be remiss
if i didn't acknowledge my republican
colleagues
who joined us on this occasion
over the year
to achieve this goal
in closing
i want to thank chairman durbin for the
beautiful beautifully executing this
nomination process
it was equal parts fair thorough and
expeditious
no easy feat
in this modern senate
i want to thank all of my democratic
colleagues on the judiciary committee
you were just fabulous every one of you
for your respectful and insightful
examination of the judge's record
and i want to thank my republican
colleagues who chose to take this
process seriously no matter which side
you voted on
the president sent us an impressive
nominee
she married a robust and thoughtful and
lively examination
i thank the members who did it precisely
that
in short madam president
this is one of the great moments
of american history
at the time of our constitution's
ratification
in most states you had to be a white
male protestant landowner
to be considered part of american
society
so from the get-go
generations of americans have sought to
establish the united states as a full
democracy
we fought a bloody civil war to end
slavery when women organized and reached
for the ballot the civil rights movement
brought an end to the vicious
segregation
of the mid-20th century
and today
we are taking a giant
bold and important step
on the well-trodden path
to fulfilling our country's
founding promise
this is a great moment
for judge jackson
but it is even great
a greater moment for america as we rise
to a more perfect union
i thank my colleagues for their work and
i yield the floor
under the previous order all
post-cloture time has expired
the question occurs on the nomination
of katanji brown jackson
of the district of columbia
to be an associate justice
of the supreme court of the united
states
i asked for the a's and nays
is there a sufficient second
there is
and certainly appears to be a sufficient
second the clerk will call the role
ms baldwin
miss baldwin i
mr barrasso
mr barrasso no
mr bennett
mr bennett i mrs blackburn
mrs blackburn no mr blumenthal
mr blumenthal aye mr blunt
mr blunt
no mr booker
mr booker
aye mr bozeman
mr bozeman no mr brawn
mr braun
no mr brown
mr brown i mr burr
mr burr no miss cantwell
ms cantwell aye mrs capito
mrs capito no mr cardin
mr cardin aye mr carper
mr carper aye mr casey
mr casey aye mr cassidy
mr cassidy no miss collins
miss collins i mr coons
mr coons aye mr corning
mr cornyn no miss cortez masto
miss cortes masto aye mr cotton
mr cotton no mr kramer
mr kramer
no mr crapo
mr crapo no mr cruz
mr cruz no mr danes
mr danes no
miss duckworth
ms duckworth i mr durbin
mr durbin
i
miss ernst
miss ernst
no
mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein
i mrs fisher
mrs fisher
no mrs gillibrand
mrs gillibrand
aye mr graham
mr grassley
mr grassley
no mr haggerty
mr hagerty no
miss hassan
miss hassan
aye mr hawley
mr hawley
no mr heinrich
mr heinrich
aye mr hickenlooper
mr hickenlooper
i miss hirono
miss hirono
i mr hoeven
mr hoeven
no mrs hyde smith
mrs hyde smith
no mr inhofe mr inhofe
no
mr johnson
mr johnson
no
mr kane
kane
i
mr kelly
mr kelly
aye
mr kennedy
mr kennedy
no
mr king
mr king
i miss klobuchar
miss klobuchar
i mr lankford
mr lankford
no
mr leahy
mr leahy
aye mr lee
mr lee
no
mr luhan
mr lujan
i
miss lumus
miss lumis
no
mr mansion
mr mansion
aye mr markey
mr markey
aye mr marshall
mr marshall
no mr mcconnell
mr mcconnell
no
mr menendez
mr menendez
i
mr merkley
mr merkley
i
mr moran
mr moran voted in the negative ms
murkowski
ms murkowski
aye mr murphy mr murphy
aye mrs murray
mrs murray
aye
mr assaf
mr assaf
aye mr padilla aye mr padilla
aye mr paul
mr peters aye
mr peters
aye mr portman
mr portman
no mr reed
mr reed
aye mr rish
mr rish
no mr romney
mr romney
i miss rosen
miss rosen
aye mr rounds
mr rounds
no
mr rubio
mr rubio
no mr sanders
mr sanders
i
mr sass
mr sass
no
mr schatz mr schatz
aye mr schumer
mr schumer
i mr scott of florida
mr scott of florida
no mr scott of south carolina
mr scott of south carolina
no mrs shaheen
mrs shaheen
aye mr shelby
mr shelby
no
miss cinema
miss cinema
i miss smith
miss smith
aye ms stabenow
ms stabenow
aye mr sullivan
mr sullivan
no
mr tester mr tester
mr thune
mr thune
no mr tillis
mr tillis
no mr toomey
mr toomey
no
mr tuberville
mr tuberville
no mr van hollen
mr van hollen
aye mr warner
mr warner
aye mr warnock
aye
mr warnock aye ms warren
ms warren
aye mr whitehouse
mr whitehouse aye mr wicker
mr wicker
no mr wyden mr wyden
aye mr young
mr young
no
mr graham mr graham
no
[Music]
[Music]
okay
now
thank you
so
food
[Music]
[Music]
mr paul mr paul
no
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
on this vote the a's are 53
the nays are 47
and this nomination is confirmed
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
under the previous order
the motion to reconsider
is considered made and laid upon the
table
and the president will immediately
be notified of the senate's action
madam president
very happily i note the absence of a
quorum
the clerk will call the roll miss
baldwin
[Music]
[Music]
so
let's see
foreign
uh
here
movie
look
um
you know there's so much stuff happening
is
i think we did pretty well
anybody seen sure
this is a great day for america
being a senator requires patience
and many days of frustration
and falling short of the goals so many
times
many people give up but others don't
you're looking at a committee that never
gave up
this is an extraordinary senate
judiciary committee
here we are in a tied senate 50-50 with
this committee at 11 to 11
and we were asked to
help this president
brings someone to the supreme court to
fill a vacancy we all know from recent
history that that is not an easy
assignment
and i want to tell you we were helped
immensely by the fact that president
biden picked the most extraordinary
individual that i could think of in
america she turned out to be a pillar of
strength
to show grace and dignity
and really won over the hearts of the
american people that's not just a
feeling it's reflected in the polling
after our first week and she's put been
going through 24 hours of questions
they asked the american people their
opinion of her and it went up
it was positive she was cool under
pressure she was solid and she really
made the case that to be the first you
have to be the best
so this committee worked long and hard
not only for this
nomination but also for other
nominations for courts in the land we
want to make our justice system look
much more like america and today we took
a giant stride forward in giving
this judge katanji brown jackson her
chance our lifetime chance to serve on
the united states supreme court i'm
going to turn it over to a former member
of the committee who's still always
welcome in the committee with the
majority leader chuck schumer thank you
well i just wanted to it is just an
amazing day
if i had to think of an adjective to
describe all of us it would be elated
elated because of this wonderful person
going on the court
elated because america
today
the higher angels as abraham lincoln
said
held forth and held true
this has been a long hard road
as we try to get to greater equality
less bigotry in america
and there is often steps backward but
when you have a day like this it
inspires you to keep moving forward
there's no better group to have us move
forward than this group i came here to
praise the judiciary committee led by
dick durbin he just did a fabulous job
and to praise all of the members of this
committee it's just in when you look
around and see
it's an amazingly talented group of
people
and they showed it
they showed it in this hearing where the
challenges were large some of the
republicans on the committee treated the
witness and the other members
respectfully but some did not you all
saw that
but this committee
held their ground
stayed cool
answered respectfully and beat back the
nastiest of arguments
so they should be very proud of
themselves because all of the senate and
all of america is proud of them
thanks chuck thank that leahy president
pro tem and former chairman of the
committee
thank you uh thank you very much mr
chairman
and first off
having chaired that committee for a
number of years
i cannot think of anybody could have
done a better job or would have done a
better job than dick durbin
and uh i must admit
chair
you kept your temper better than i would
have
but i've been here for 21
supreme court nominations
and i look at all of them and i look at
what we've learned through 21.
and here i see somebody extraordinarily
well qualified
somebody who make the court look more
like america
and somebody frankly
i could say to my children
and my grandchildren
be proud
be proud of what you see
because
over those 21.
i could not help but think it was rare
that we broke through and showed the
diversity this country should even
though we had some excellent people
but this is a problem
to go on the
supreme court
the first thing to go on the supreme
court
now
it's come all the way
and i am so happy
and so happy that
the chair kept us all together
and after
48 years
i'm very very happy thank you
i want to say one word before we open up
the questions and that is uh we're here
because of extraordinary staff work at
every level every single one of us
relied on the men and women who work
here under exceptional circumstances
with covet
to work long long long hours and to be
there when we needed them i just want to
salute them i think i joined that
open it to any questions
[Laughter]
what did you say
what kind of look did you give me um is
it any legislative
answer to anything that happened in this
hearing i i'm thinking more for a number
of you comments that i think you did
with mr chairman about the tendency
guidelines that everyone complains about
the need reform well let's start
i'm just going to speak for myself i
don't even talk to my colleagues on the
committee
i just find that
this was a trial by ordeal
she went through 24 hours of questioning
each one of us had 10 minute opening
statements and then 50 minutes minimum
50 minutes to ask questions i'm not sure
that that is really fair to any nominee
or it's neces i don't believe it's
necessary i mean you don't have to go
that far back in history to find
nominees who've gone through the
judiciary committee in a matter of
several hours
maybe a day
but now it's become an endurance contest
and i i don't think that necessarily
serves the purposes uh that we're trying
to serve in terms of issues we have
plenty of issues some were raised during
this hearing and others we're working on
i see my friend annie kobochar here who
is breaking ground in areas of any trust
and and raising questions that are
central to so many different areas i can
just go around i know that i
there's sheldon i was looking for you i
know you've got a few ideas for hearings
too same thing is true in your every one
of them what i've tried to do on these
subcommittees is to give them the
resources and the incentive to plow
forward and take on some issues that
haven't been touched in a long time they
haven't let me down we've got an
exciting committee
yes
um a few hours ago on the same platform
uh senator ted cruz and senator lindsey
graham stood there and said that if
there was another nominee by this
president and president biden
that was similar to judge
kentucky brown jackson they would not
let it go through they are in the
majority what is your response to that
well
of course we certainly hope they never
have that opportunity we want to
continue and build our majority in the
november election and i think the
american people supporting this nominee
will understand the stark differences
which some republicans would bring to
the bench
and i'd also go on to say that
now i'm going to stop there that's
enough
yes don't ruin
so
after the contentious uh confirmation
hearings um you did get three republican
codes
but it does seem as if perhaps the era
of bipartisan confirmation votes may be
behind us do you think that going
forward we can continue to look forward
to contentious hearings
and toxic partisanship for every
nominee first i can't say enough for the
three uh collins murkowski
and romney
they came through
and took grief for it uh
to a measure we rarely see around here i
respect them so much
i i held out the hope that at the last
minute several others would join them
and realize that they wanted to be on
the right side of history at this moment
it didn't pan out that way
we've got to continue to work to build
bipartisanship i'm lucky to have a man
sitting next to me on that committee and
chuck grassley who might count as a
friend and as a fair individual we
didn't agree on this nominee but there
are a lot of things we do agree on we've
got to continue to build those bridges
one more question yes
several senators have
talked along those same lines about this
process being broken in the senate in
terms of evaluating nominees are there
any specific fixes changes that you
would like to see in the way that the
senate goes about evaluating future
nominees to the court to try to get away
from the processes i i don't want to
give that off the cuff i'd rather
reflect on it it's changed i mean the
elimination of
the filibuster the elimination 60-vote
requirement
by senator mcconnell changed the
selection process very much made it much
more partisan under these circumstances
but before i start talking about
options that we can consider i want to
do it in
the cool light of the morning when we
are not as excited as we are at this
moment and i'd rather do it in that
fashion thank you very much okay one
more time
what stood out to you what was on the
forefront of your mind when you decided
i believe what i said from the start if
you want to be the first you have to be
the best
this judge brought the strongest
conceivable resume if you ever graduated
from law school and someone said you've
got a chance for a clerkship
you'd jump at it right
she had three of them at every level of
the federal court if you said you want a
person on the court who has experience
as a defender as a person who has been a
district court judge a circuit court
judge she checked every one of the boxes
and she'd been through the committee
three times with bipartisan support she
was exceptional and she had to be
because the first person to ever try to
break but down a barrier is going to be
really carefully scrutinized so you know
for me
from the beginning i thought
this president made a wise and strong
choice it's good for america
she is good for the court thanks
everybody thank you
[Music]